[Music]
you
in the last video along with the ideas
of vector addition and scalar
multiplication I described vector
coordinates where there's this back and
forth between for example pairs of
numbers and two-dimensional vectors now
I imagine the vector coordinates were
already familiar to a lot of you but
there's another kind of interesting way
to think about these coordinates which
is pretty central to linear algebra when
you have a pair of numbers that's meant
to describe a vector like three negative
two I want you to think about each
coordinate as a scalar meaning think
about how each one stretches or squishes
vectors in the XY coordinate system
there are two very special vectors the
one pointing to the right with length
one commonly called I hat or the unit
vector in the X direction and the one
pointing straight up with length one
commonly called J hat or the unit vector
in the Y direction now think of the x
coordinate of our vector as a scalar
that scales I hat stretching it by a
factor of three and the y coordinate is
a scalar that scales J hat flipping it
and stretching it by a factor of two in
this sense the vector that these
coordinates describe is the sum of two
scaled vectors that's a surprisingly
important concept this idea of adding
together two scaled vectors
those two vectors I had in j-hat have a
special name by the way
together they're called the basis of a
coordinate system what this means
basically is that when you think about
coordinates of scalars the basis vectors
are what those scalars actually you know
scale there's also a more technical
definition but I'll get to that later
by Framing our coordinate system in
terms of these two special basis vectors
it raises a pretty interesting and
subtle point we could have chosen
different basis vectors and gotten a
completely reasonable new coordinate
system for example take some vector
pointing up into the right along with
some other vector pointing down into the
right in some way take a moment to think
about all the different vectors that you
can get by choosing two scalars using
each one to scale one of the vectors
then adding together what you get which
two dimensional vectors can you reach by
altering the choices of scalars
the answer is that you can reach every
possible two-dimensional vector and I
think it's a good puzzle to contemplate
why
a new pair of basis vectors like this
still gives us a valid way to go back
and forth between pairs of numbers and
two-dimensional vectors but the
Association is definitely different from
the one that you get using the more
standard basis of I hat and J hat this
is something I'll go into much more
detail on later describing the exact
relationship between different
coordinate systems but for right now I
just want you to appreciate the fact
that anytime we describe vectors
numerically it depends on an implicit
choice of what basis vectors were using
so anytime that you're scaling two
vectors and adding them like this it's
called a linear combination of those two
vectors
where does this word linear come from
why does this have anything to do with
lines well this isn't the etymology but
one way I like to think about it is that
if you fix one of those scalars and let
the other one change its value freely
the tip of the resulting vector draws a
straight line
now if you let both scalars range freely
and consider every possible vector that
you can get there are two things that
can happen for most pairs of vectors
you'll be able to reach every possible
point in the plane every two-dimensional
vector is within your grasp however in
the unlucky case where your two original
vectors happen to line up the tip of the
resulting vector is limited to just the
single line passing through the origin
actually technically there's a third
possibility to both your vectors could
be zero in which case you just be stuck
at the origin here's some more
terminology the set of all possible
vectors that you can reach with a linear
combination of a given pair of vectors
is called the span of those two vectors
so restating what we just saw in this
lingo the span of most pairs of 2d
vectors is all vectors of 2d space but
when they line up their span is all
vectors whose tip sit on a certain line
remember how I said that linear algebra
revolves around vector addition and
scalar multiplication
well the span of two vectors is
basically a way of asking what are all
the possible vectors you can reach using
only these two fundamental operations
vector addition and scalar
multiplication this is a good time to
talk about how people commonly think
about vectors as points it gets really
crowded to think about a whole
collection of vectors sitting on a line
and more crowded still to think about
all two-dimensional vectors all at once
filling up the plane so when dealing
with collections of vectors like this
it's common to represent each one with
just a point in space the point at the
tip of that vector where as usual I want
you thinking about that vector with its
tail on the origin that way if you want
to think about every possible vector
whose tip sits on a certain line just
think about the line itself
likewise to think about all possible
two-dimensional vectors all at once
conceptualize each one as the point
where its tips its so in effect what
you'll be thinking about is the infinite
flat sheet of two-dimensional space
itself leaving the arrows out of it
in general if you're thinking about a
vector on its own think of it as an
arrow and if you're dealing with a
collection of vectors it's convenient to
think of them all as points so for our
span example the span of most pairs of
vectors ends up being the entire
infinite sheet of two-dimensional space
but if they line up their span is just a
line
the idea of span gets a lot more
interesting if we start thinking about
vectors in three-dimensional space for
example if you take two vectors in 3d
space that are not pointing in the same
direction what does it mean to take
their span well their span is the
collection of all possible linear
combinations of those two vectors
meaning all possible vectors you get by
scaling each of the two of them in some
way and then adding them together you
can kind of imagine turning to different
knobs to change the two scalars defining
the linear combination adding the scaled
vectors and following the tip of the
resulting vector that tip will trace out
some kind of flat sheet cutting through
the origin of three-dimensional space
this flat sheet is the span of the two
vectors or more precisely the set of all
possible vectors whose tips sit on that
flat sheet is the span of your two
vectors isn't that a beautiful mental
image so what happens if we add a third
vector and consider the span of all
three of those guys a linear combination
of three vectors is defined pretty much
the same way as it is for two you'll
choose three different scalars scale
each of those vectors and then add them
all together
and again the span of these vectors is
the set of all possible linear
combinations
two different things could happen here
if your third vector happens to be
sitting on the span of the first two
then the span doesn't change you're sort
of trapped on that same flat sheet in
other words adding a scaled version of
that third vector to the linear
combination doesn't really give you
access to any new vectors but if you
just randomly choose a third vector it's
almost certainly not sitting on the span
of those first two then since it's
pointing in a separate direction it
unlocks access to every possible
three-dimensional vector one way I like
to think about this is that as you scale
that new third vector it moves around
that span sheet of the first two
sweeping it through all of space another
way to think about it is that you're
making full use of the three freely
changing scalars that you have at your
disposal to access the full three
dimensions of space
now in the case where the third vector
was already sitting on the span of the
first two or the case where two vectors
happen to line up we want some
terminology to describe the fact that at
least one of these vectors is redundant
not adding anything to our span whenever
this happens where you have multiple
vectors and you could remove one without
reducing the span the relevant
terminology is to say that they are
linearly dependent another way of
phrasing that would be to say that one
of the vectors can be expressed as a
linear combination of the others since
it's already in the span of the others
on the other hand if each vector really
does add another dimension to this ban
they're said to be linearly independent
so with all of that terminology
with some good mental images to go with
it let me leave you with a puzzle before
we go the technical definition of a
basis of a space is a set of linearly
independent vectors that span that space
now given how I described a basis
earlier and given your current
understanding of the words span and
linearly independent think about why
this definition would make sense
in the next video I'll get into matrices
and transforming space see you then
you